[Music]
monsoon season is here and people in the
southwest part of the valley know far
too well what can happen people
mountain's edge experience heavy rain
and floods last summer nearly one year
ago 8 News Now reporter Joe Moller is
live near Fort Apache and Gummer with
more from our brace for the storm
coverage Joe yeah hey there Ted that
storm struck here and late July of last
year like you mentioned we're near Fort
Apache and go more in that channel that
failed as this one right behind us here
in the southwest corner of that
intersection water rushed out of this
channel and filled the streets of this
nearby neighborhood we talked to several
people in there who say they're happy to
the issue that they were having here was
now fixed I saw it earlier that morning
Michael Woods remembers the water
filling several streets in his
neighborhood last summer I start going
down Goldman they flooded this street
and the next street Oh
he says the water didn't cause too many
problems but did go up his driveway some
others had more issues but some of the
people that was going in a garages say
father there Steven parish from the
Clark County Flood Control District says
a part of a nearby channel failed one
reason or another that channel didn't
hold up and a bank of the of the channel
broke out and so water actually ran out
of the channel and down one of the
streets there he says since last summer
developer KB Homes repaired the channel
with more rock and concrete to prevent a
break so they fortified and reinforced
that that make better so if a similar
storm were to occur this summer they
should be a challenge to work quite a
bit better than it last year he says
despite it being fixed people should
always be prepared and vigilant the good
news is that it's fixed now and we're
happy that subdivision is going to be
protected
and woods and other residents we spoke
to in the neighborhood say they're happy
to know that this is fixed and now
they're not as worried if another
monsoon does roll through reporting live
the mountains edge Joe Moller
ladies now